my name is Bob James yep that is the  legendary British doctor I'm Roger Moore  he passed away today in Switzerland at  the age of 89  after a short belt with cancer war was  of course best known for playing agent  double-oh seventh James Bond films from  1973 to 1985 fair when I think of James  Bond it's Rogers face that comes to my  mind really is I mean he was the bond  with the dry/wet  inspector but finds on the way to play  Bond who words cheaply I know my name is  bond I don't know why I didn't go into  comedy maybe it's because I'm not very  good at it and Moore became Sir Roger  when he received a knighthood in 2003  and one of his later roles was as a  villain in the 1997 Spice Girls movies  spice world it is time to hang your  pants on the book of darkness more  leaves behind his wife Christina and  three children and a private funeral  will be held for him in Monaco or yet  another legend laws yes certainly gonna  be missed  you